capita spesso che le nuove tecnologie
vengano prese con un po di diffidenza da
parte della opinione pubblica ea questa
cosa non stanno sfuggendo i veicoli
elettrici che sono spesso al centro di
varie polemiche
nessun oggetto anche di opinioni molto
contrastanti tra di loro che provocano
della confusione
se siete degli appassionati vi sarà
capitato sicuramente di leggere o di
sentiere importanti pareri e autorevoli
pareri che riportano i risultati di
alcuni studi che vogliono che
addirittura le auto elettriche siano più
impattanti dal punto di vista ambientale
delle tradizionali auto con motori a
combustione interna sono walter
vinciotti sono un ingegnere sono un bel
system integrator quindi lavoro su
veicoli elettrici ed insieme andremo ad
esaminare quali sono i fattori che
possono influenzare uno studio tanto da
spostare l'ago della bilancia a favore
dei veicoli elettrici piuttosto che dei
veicoli tradizionali e combustione
interna
inizieremo facendo un confronto tra un
veicolo elettrico e un veicolo con
motore a combustione interna durante il
loro normale utilizzo
il veicolo con motore a combustione
interna avrà delle emissioni di gas che
sono appunto i prodotti di combustione
all'interno di questi gas possiamo
trovare la mia vide carbonica che è
responsabile dell'effetto serra e quindi
del surriscaldamento globale ma non è
l'unico componente gas di scarico di un
veicolo in realtà contengono anche altri
prodotti di combustione come ad esempio
il monossido di carbonio piuttosto che i
vari ossidi di azoto un veicolo
elettrico al contrario durante
il normale funzionamento non ha alcun
tipo di emissione a un motore elettrico
che viene alimentato da una batteria a
questo punto normalmente il detrattore
delle veicoli elettrici a un'altra
obiezione da da sollevare che è sì ma
dove c'è energia elettrica normalmente a
monte c'è stata una combustione quella
che è necessaria per produrre l'energia
elettrica quindi non abbiamo realmente
risolto un problema ma tutt'al più lo
abbiamo spostato questa affermazione in
realtà non è del tutto corretta perché
non necessariamente la produzione di
energia elettrica necessita di
combustioni a monte
basti pensare alle energie rinnovabili
che attraverso le pannelli fotovoltaici
degli impianti idroelettrici lascia
produrre energia elettrica in quantità
senza bisogna appunto di avere delle
combustioni a morte
come è possibile allora che ci siano
delle opinioni così contrastanti sul
fatto che un'auto elettrica possa
inquinare di meno di una di
un'automobile tradizionale questo è
dovuto principalmente al fatto che in
maniera corretta se si vuole valutare
l'impatto ambientale maniera corretta di
un determinato bene vanno considerate
anche la fase di produzione di quel bene
e la successiva fase di smaltimento in
queste due fasi il la tecnologia che
serve per la produzione specialmente
delle batterie in un veicolo elettrico
soffre di qualche guaio di gioventù nel
senso che mentre l'industria
automobilistica in 30 40 anni di
evoluzione ha avuto la possibilità di
consolidare di strutturare dei processi
molto rigidi e
ottimizzati nella produzione dei propri
componenti nelle autore perché tutto in
specialmente in questo periodo è tutto
in continuo divenire quindi anche le
tecnologie che si stanno susseguendo non
hanno ancora avuto il tempo e il modo di
arrivare alla loro maturità quali sono
quindi quei fattori che possono
influenzare lo studio e spostare l'ago
della bilancia a favore di un veicolo
elettrico piuttosto che a favore di un
veicolo tradizionale fondamentalmente
individuiamo due parametri
il primo è la vita utile preso in
considerazione tutti gli studi che
riportano dei valori negativi a carico
delle auto elettriche
lo fanno considerando una vita è utile
del veicolo di appena 150 mila
chilometri
questo dato andrebbe rivisto anche
perché considerate che un normale
costruttore di automobili garantisce un
segmento c ad esempio per almeno 210 240
mila chilometri a seconda delle modalità
di utilizzo è chiaro che andare a
considerare una vita utile del prodotto
inferiore va a discapito delle auto
elettriche che hanno il loro vantaggio
proprio durante il loro utilizzo è no
nella fase di
fabbricazione e in quella successiva di
smaltimento
un altro fattore da tenere in
considerazione che spesso troviamo in
questo genere di studi e la sostituzione
della batteria
anche in questo caso è un dato che
andrebbe fortemente aggiornato i
produttori di batterie ad oggi
garantiscono le loro batterie per
all'incirca 180 200mila chilometri
quindi le garantiscono per un valore di
chilometri bene al di sopra di quella
che viene considerata la vita utile
ovvero 150.000 km capirete benissimo che
non ha alcun senso ipotizzare che a 75
mila chilometri un'auto un'auto
elettrica moderna debba sostituire la
propria batteria
considerando correttamente i due
parametri citate ovvero la vita utile e
il fatto di non dover sostituire una
batteria
gli studi attualmente riportano ben
altri risultati
ve ne cito alcuni in termini di
emissioni di co2 quindi di anidride
carbonica un veicolo elettrico
attualmente ha dei vantaggi ci arrivano
fino al 55 per cento rispetto a vetture
a veicoli con con motori a benzina e
arrivano fino al 40 per cento rispetto
ai motori diesel
abbiamo quindi individuato nella
batteria
sicuramente l'elemento più critico di
tutta la filiera dalla produzione fino
allo smaltimento ed i componenti dei
veicoli elettrici
l'obiettivo è quello di lavorare per
migliorare l'efficienza sia nella fase
di produzione che appunto in quella di
smaltimento
nella strada è stata già assegnata ad
esempio quest'anno nel mese di settembre
2020 perla annunciato l'inizio della
fase di validazione di celle che si
produrrà in proprio quindi iniziando ad
evitare i costi e soprattutto l'impatto
ambientale dovuto al trasporto delle
celle dalle siti di produzione fino alle
proprie giga factory dove vengono
assemblate le batterie
queste nuove celle inoltre hanno delle
caratteristiche particolari loro layout
è stato semplificato in modo da essere
più facilmente producibili senza
impegnare grandi risorse energetiche e
quindi tutto a vantaggio del ciclo di
vita della batteria
un altro esempio che possiamo fare di
per core di percorso virtuoso nel
miglioramento delle performance delle
batterie e ad esempio quello del colosso
cinese sia itl che ha annunciato anche
loro hanno fatto quest'anno la
produzione di nuove celle strutturali
che cosa significa c'è la strutturale
significa che queste celle potranno
essere utilizzate all'interno del telaio
del veicolo stesso oppure vista ancora
meglio
sarà la batteria che potrà andare a
svolgere il ruolo del telaio all'interno
del veicolo
in questa maniera i due processi
produttivi quello della batteria è
quello del telaio vengono fusi e
ottimizzati in un unico progetto con
notevoli risparmi in termini di
emissioni
non cede bisogna dare quindi fiducia ai
produttori di veicoli elettrici e di
batterie in questo momento stanno
lavorando per ottimizzare anche quei
processi che oggi costituiscono un
elemento critico in tutta la catena di
gestione del veicolo elettrico i veicoli
elettrici sicuramente non salveranno il
mondo ma potranno contribuire a renderlo
un posto migliore in cui vivere